Now that we know the inputs and the outputs,
the procedure almost writes itself,
especially since we already know the code
that we want to execute before we define the procedure.
I am going to write the procedure by modifying the code here.
First, what we're going to do is make a little space,
erasing the code that's not part of the four lines that we want to turn into the procedure.
So, I haven't modified the code at all.
What I have is almost exactly what I need for the body of the procedure.
This is what we want to do.
What we need to do is modify that to get in the inputs
and turn it into a procedure.
To make it a procedure, we need to use the "def" name syntax.
We're going to define the procedure "get&#95;next&#95;target."
We need our input, and we decided what the input should be.
Now we need our parameters.
The parameters are the inputs to the procedure.
We decided what the inputs should be are the web contents—
that's a string giving the contents of the web page.
That's what we had in the variable "page"—and
we can call that "page" again here.
That's what we're passing in as our input.
Now we have the body of the procedure.
The code is exactly the same as the code we had before,
but instead of "page" being whatever it was here,
"page" is whatever we pass in as the input to the procedure.
We can change the name of "page."
It makes sense to change that name.
This code works no matter what we pass in.
It doesn't have to be a web page.
Any string that we pass in, this code will find it.
It makes more sense to give it a slightly more generic name.
We'll change the name to "S."
If we change the name of the parameter,
well everywhere that we use page,
now we don't have the value of "page."
What we have is the value of "S,"
which is the name of the parameter.
We'll change all of those to "S's" as well.
We're almost done.
There's one big thing that we have left to do,
and that's how do we get the outputs.
We said what we want the outputs to be is the URL
and the value of "end_quote," so we need some way of getting those back.
The way that you do that is to use "return."
"Return" is a special construct in Python.
We have the keyword "return,"
followed by a list of all the things that we want to "return" from the procedure.
What we return is a list of any number of expressions,
separated by commas.
We can have zero "return" expressions; that would mean there's no output.
It actually is useful to have procedures with no outputs sometimes.
That's not true if we just think of procedures as things that map inputs to outputs,
but procedures can also do other things.
They can do what we call "side effects."
Side effects are things that we can see but that aren't the outputs.
An example of a side effect would be if we printed something out,
we would see that "result" happen.
We see everything that happens when the code and procedure runs—
but we wouldn't get it as an output.
In this case, we do want to have outputs from "get&#95;next&#95;target."
We want to "return" results so we know how to continue.
We decided what the outputs should be, are the value of the url
We want to find the string that's the next target and the value of the end quote,
so we know the position where it was found.
Let's see if you can figure out how to finish the return statement.
Your goal is to figure out the code that we need after the return to
to finish this procedure.